the other problem was every naturalist
face and it goes back to the discussion
of meaning is a naturalistic account of
semantic meeting and naturalist have
been working for at least fifty years on
this subject and with no interesting
agreed-upon consensus and here there is
a divide of which Terry represents a
significant path um if we assume that
the intentionality of written
inscriptions and vocal disturbances in
the air is due to the intentionality the
original intentionality of
great states then we need an account of
how brain states can represent can be
semantically valuable can have truth
values can express propositions but via
some kind of inscription all devices and
at least so far we have not had a
entirely satisfactory account of how
that's possible and my own view which
stems from reading a book called content
and consciousness of a long time ago is
that owing to the fact that our brains
are Darwinian systems we will never have
such an account now let me well I didn't
say that was in the book I said we're
going to my reading
but of course there are those who say
like Terry that the mistake in this
identification of the problem stems from
the idea that meaning the meaning of
speech and inscriptions is derived from
the meaning of brain States and that
meaning exists independently of brain
States
hey the last part is not what I would
say okay
absolutely that brain state there's no
meaning but well I think the real
problem is this identification of a
thought with a brain state I yes our
brain is going through lots of things
doing lots of things but I would view
meaningful content yeah that's right so
the meaningful content of a thought I
don't think is that that's the identity
theory that I'm done troubled by the
identity theory says and we can do it in
all different ways that I have brain
state a and that's thought B my view of
that is that that's a mistake I think
that the brain state is like the words
he's typing on his computer it
represents something but that
representation is not the brain state
that is the content or you might say the
aboutness is not the brain state the
brain state is a it is a medium and just
like the words typed on a computer or
the sounds I'm making that the reference
of that the meaning of that is not that
so else do you do types journalism yes
we're gonna have to explain that I know
what you're not
yes yes you were so I think that's
really really important if we wind of it
and it is it does matter in
consciousness right I mean it's I was
getting at it in my remark a few minutes
ago about needing scaffolding to
construct itself but the externalism
about semantic meaning is a little bit
simpler right it's the idea that the
meaning of a word or the meaning of
anything is a function of coordination
among agents who use those devices
to to represent information to one
another and so part of the identity part
of the meaning I don't take the word
represent you have engaged in a regress
which you will now have to catch okay
okay
fair enough sure but so so so that's
let's park that and agree that the
goodness we don't but we use various
devices for coordinating our
expectations with one another and cool
and and that coordination of
expectations is itself an information
sharing and conveying process and we
depend on all sorts of external
environmental conditions being right
some of which we also manipulate I mean
we maintain the environmental conditions
so is to maintain the stability of the
conventional signs that we use that's
true of words its troops its of all the
components of natural language we we of
course convey information we use a law
besides language right we have
conventional gestures but we also have
the social structures structures that we
build in code all kinds of information
and guide us and constrain the way will
interpret one another lots of our
institutional trappings are like that
that's another word you like I'll have
to cache it interpret which one
interpreter again because that's just
another intentional yeah but now so so
okay so let's look let's so but first
the key externalist point is a brain a
brain state thought of a brain state of
me regarded as just with respect to its
physiological properties or its neuro
chemical properties doesn't in itself
have any stable meaning or reference
though it the existence of various
states of that kind will be necessary
conditions from by producing things that
in some community of information shares
have meaning and referencing other
semantic property externalism
is simply obviously true of something
like bank balances absolutely there are
no money looking at the the computer
program looking at the data structure of
the computers and how on the earth can
this beasts money you're never gonna see
it if you look locally you have to see
the role as playing so in the larger
system then it's obvious but now it says
we must so now tell me how this story
works for something like or hey look or
4x Wow
simcha chromatic terms oh so this is the
story that works interest and actually I
don't think words at all but it's it
works for cat
maybe but but how does it work for
something like alright you come across
somebody in the supermarket and you see
they have a shopping list in their hand
they're going down and the third thing
I'm the on the list says cheddar or
breathe okay
and you decide well this probably means
get either some cheddar or some Brie and
sure enough that's what it means and
this the the or there has intentionality
it has meaning in virtually the role at
place in the shoppers activities so if
it weren't the chakra having the
activities then or wouldn't mean a damn
thing it doesn't you can don't look at
the end that's not where it is you have
to see how war is playing the role not
just on the piece of paper but in the
whole system
of the projects of the Shocker now very
simple rip up the list and put it in the
chakras head same story there states in
the brain have their meaning because
they are being used by the person who is
the shopper a shopping list in the head
is derived intentionality just as much
as a shopping list on a piece of paper
you